tout petit mot puisqu'on a parlé
d'Emmanuel Macron vous m'avez pas
interrogé là-dessus je pense qu'on
traite le sujet un tout petit peu
pardessus la jambe en considérant que
dans le fond ce renouvellement qu'on
voit pousser partout en France Emmanuel
Macron à gauche Yannick Jade qui prend
la place de cicile Duflot chez les Verts
ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance ne
laissons pas le monopole du
renouvellement politique à la gauche il
serait bon aussi que chez nous à droite
au centre on soit capable de montrer que
il y a des idées nouvelles il y a des
visages nouveaux on est capable de
changer pourquoi ça fonctionne pas alors
avec vous et qu'est-ce qui vous dit
jean-pierret de cabach qu'est-ce qui
vous dit que ça ne va pas fonctionner
vous connaissez déjà le résultat de
dimanche vous savez ce que vont voter
les Français vous savez il y a une
France des sondages il y a une France
des commentateurs il y a une France des
journalistes elle est totalement libre
elle a le droit de commenter et puis la
France des France Lund matin et la
France Monsieur elkabache je suis
candidat à la primaire ça mérite tout
simplement le respect de votre part